im bayerischen amberg plant die stadt
schier unglaubliches mitten auf die
postler straße will die verwaltung eine
mauer bauen
der grund die stadt will
erschließungskosten kassieren für ausbau
und sanierung der straße kommt aber mit
den bauarbeiten nur bis zur straßenmitte
um das fertige teilstück schon mal
abzurechnen sollen aus der durchgehenden
straße zwei sackgassen werden für die
betroffenen anlieger eine geschichte aus
dem tollhaus
ein taschenspielertrick der stadt amberg
um gebühren erheben zu können ich habe
es wie ein aprilscherz gehalten im
ersten moment habe ich schallend gelacht
da hab ich gesagt wo soll denn hin
jetzt kann ja gar nicht sein die mauer
wird nur um abrechnen zu können
hingebaut also sie hat ja keinen zweck
sie erfüllt keinen zweck sie erfüllt nur
ein abrechnungszwecke im september 2010
liegen die bagger los die straße wird
saniert und verbreitert dazu allerdings
braucht die stadt ein paar quadratmeter
grund von den anliegern eine
eigentümerin aber verkauft nicht deshalb
ist auf halber strecke schluss mit dem
ausbau kassieren kann die stadt aber
erst wenn die ganze straße fertig ist um
nicht auf den kosten sitzen zu bleiben
hat man im rathaus eine idee man baut
einfach eine mauer
dadurch wird der sanierte abschnitt zur
eigenen straße und kann abgerechnet
werden so der plan
wenn es zu einer mauer kommen sollte
käme hier kein rettungsfahrzeug keine
feuerwerk einen umzugswagen kein
lieferwagen kein paketdienst mehr durch
die straße durch und das ist eine
zumutung für die stadt geht es um
225.000 euro nur mit dem bau einer mauer
kann man dieses geld auch einfordern so
der oberbürgermeister
um die kosten der ersterschließung auch
auf die grundstücksbesitzer umzulegen
ist es nach der geänderten
rechtsprechung leider notwendig dass
eine optische abtrennung erfolgt die
klarmacht wo der erste bauabschnitt
endet die optische abtrennung die hier
geplant ist halten die betroffenen
menschen schlicht
für eine frechheit es ist unfassbar ist
das versteht kein mensch das damals so
sauer bin ich schon ja sauer bin ich
schon denn ich möchte weiterhin aus
meiner garage heraus fahren können
jetzt versucht die stadt das fehlende
grundstück über ein enteignungsverfahren
zu bekommen und die straße fertig zu
bauen das alles müsste bis april
nächsten jahres passieren ansonsten
verjähren die ansprüche so eine mauer
ist da doch deutlich schneller gebaut